aujourd'hui laurent et son épouse ont
récupéré ce bien grâce à un arrêté
d'expulsion des squatteurs de la
préfecture le 19 mai lorsque vous signez
personne ne vous dit qu'il ya une
famille avec quatre personnes bah non
c'est marqué que ces libres de toute
occupation l'occasion est pourtant son
agent immobilier à droite dit exactement
le contraire et en l'occurrence da le
bien était déjà occupée nous avons
appris que laurent et son épouse sont
poursuivis pour trafic de stupéfiants et
détention d'armes depuis octobre la
famille de squatters filmé ici jeudi
dernier a été violemment agressé par
huit inconnus cagoulés alors qu'elle
quittait les lieux elle a été relogée
par la préfecture et porte plainte pour
agression escroquerie car elle affirme
avoir versé de l'argent à un
intermédiaire pour être logés dans cette
maison
c'est de fonder une histoire de cornecul
comme on dit jeune importe quoi c'est
une expression qui a donné 40 pour tout
vous dire on adore aussi 50 fois le mec
qui n'importe quoi ouais qu'est ce que
tu dis je peux parler ou pas je vous dis
c'est une histoire de cons parce que le
mec
c'est lamentable le mec ce qu'ils sont
et tunisien les tunisiens qui sont
partis très pauvre il n'en dit qu'ils
ont payé 120 mille euros la maison sans
aucun document officiel cash en cash ça
n'existe pas ce n'est pas possible on
peut déjà y longtemps maintenant qu'on
les a agressées c'est scandaleux alors
maintenant il n'est pas prouvé que ce
soit selon lui des banalités mais non
c'est vachement intéressant ce que je
dis à tout le monde quand je précise les
choses ah ouais pour escroquerie pas
d'horizon un récépissé ces fameux 110000
euros qu'ils auraient payé en race corse
est un intermédiaire et c'est pour ça
qu'ils porteront pas possible sur la
partie non ben vas-y les médias je
trouve que les médias sont tous dans
cette affaire déjà l'an du jt de tf1 ils
disent ils rappellent le casier
judiciaire de ce monsieur est juste
après ils évoquent le fait que la
famille est agressée comme s'il pourrait
être responsable de ça déjà c'est
honteux et c'est fou dans la manière
dont les médias traitent une information
change la perception qu'on en a là on
parle de famille agressée comme si
c'était une famille victime et faut
rappeler que cette famille au départ
elle est coupable puisque c'est une
famille de squatters donc arrêter les
traiter comme des victimes au départ la
victime c'est laurent et les coupables
ce sont les squares